But it is possible that some new form of some new form of particle,
something else could be discovered.
Yeah that will know about it yet.
Cause we know,
almost know that there,
there are other particles out there in the universe.
We almost know cause I think called dark matter.
So we look out into the universe and we see that there's a lot of stuff there
that's an interacting gravitationally,
but he's not interacting strongly with the matter out of which we are made and
the stars are made.
So it it,
it's almost certain that that's some form of particle that that fits
beautifully.
And we see lots of different observations,
the way galaxies rotate and interacts and even the oldest light in the universe,
the so called cosmic microwave background radiation,
we see the signature of that stuff in that light as well.
So we think that there's some of the particle out there.
And,
and to be honest,
we thought we would have detected it.
I think at LHC where we have lots of theories called supersymmetric theories
that make predictions of all sorts of different particles that would interact
weekly with normal matter.
And I,
yeah,
I think it's broadly seen as a surprise that we haven't seen them at Lac.
So that just may well mean either they're,
they're very,
they're,
they're a bit too massive,
so we need more energy to make them and we just haven't quite got enough or
we're not making enough of them often enough to see them,
which is one of the reasons we're upgrading the LHC.
So we also look for them by the way,
I'm directly,
so we have experiments and the mountains,
we vary them and demand sin.
So the cosmic rays from space don't interfere with them.
And we're looking for the rare occasions when these dark matter particles
bumping into the particles of matter in the detector.
So it's a the cause the idea will be these rooms full of them.
I mean the,
the galaxy swimming with that matter as far as we can tell,
but interacts very weakly with this matter.
So he doesn't bump into us very often.
So we are looking for the direct detection of it and we are looking to make
those particles LHC.
So it's everywhere,
but it doesn't interact with us very weekly.
Um,
so interacts through gravity and the,
the,
the archetypical particle that's everywhere that doesn't interact strongly is
the neutrino.
So we do know about neutrinos.
We've detected those.
And there,
there are something like 60 billion per centimeter squared per second passing
through your head now from the sun.
So they get made in nuclear reactions in the sun,
but they go straight through your head and then be straight through the earth.
Pretty much.
Uh,
occasionally one of them bumps into something and we can detect those cars were
so many of them going through.
But we only say,
you know,
I don't know,
one or two a day.
And the ideas that dark matter encompasses an enormous percentage of the
universe.
Yes,
it's five times as much matter is it dark matter than is normal matter.
And the number is 25% of the universe.
So it was roughly speaking,
but 5% of the universities,
normal matter,
the styles in gas,
you know,
25% is dark matter.
Yeah.
So that,
yeah,
five,
no,
I'm at about 25 dark matter.
And about 70 is dark energy.
That's the other thing.
The other thing,
yeah.
So what the hell's that?
Don't know.
No,
what he does.
So again,
we'll see if we got it.
We talked about Einstein's theory earlier.
So Einstein's theory,
which works spectacularly well say,
is that if you put stuff into the university,
we said before then he walks and deforms and stretches and it very precisely
tells you,
given the stuff that you put in it,
how much does it stretch and how does it stretch?
And the,
the measurement we have is how,
how it's stretching.
So,
so we,
we observed the thing we observe is how the universe is expanding and how that
expansion rate is changing and how is that how it changed over time.
So we have very precise measurements of that.
So then we can use the theory to tell us what's in it given that we know how
it's responding to that stuff.
And that's how we discovered dark energy.
So we noticed that the university's expansion rate is increasing.
So the university accelerating in its expansion,
which is exactly the opposite of what we thought.
And this is in the 1990s that we discovered that so we can work out what sort of
stuff and how much of that stuff you need to put in the universe to make that
happen.
And that's where we get these numbers from.
Um,
was there resistance to that and that was first proposed?
Yeah,
I remember my,
one of my friends that Brian Schmidt and got the Nobel prize for that.
And um,
I remember I talked to him and he said,
uh,
it was a Postdoc,
I think at the time.
So young researcher and he made it,
he's making measurements of Supernova,
the light from supernova explosions,
which are so bright that you can see them,
you know,
hundreds of million,
billions of light years away.
And he noticed that if you look at the data,
the light is stretched in the wrong way.
So we look at the stretch of light as it travels across the universe and the
universe and expanding.
It stretches the lights so it changes the color.
And he noticed that there was a discrepancy,
which,
which said that the universe,
that the expansion rate is speeding up.
It's been speeding up from I think something like 7 billion years or so.
He's been speeding up.
Um,
so he thought these gentlemen wrong cause it,
you know,
so.
So he checked in,
checked in,
checked it and he couldn't find anything wrong,
so he did what a good scientist does,
which is he published date so that somebody else could find out what he'd done
wrong and he said that he thought it would be the end of his career.
He thought I'd be a laughing stock and he got the Nobel prize because he was
right.
It is stretch.
Wow.
It's a great lesson.
Means that if you,
if you're sure that you can't see what you've done wrong,
then you publish it because of actually that thing about humility we talked
about earlier.
You know what we ultimately,
we're not trying to be right.
We're trying to find out stuff and so they're a scientists will be really happy
if they set out to be wrong because they've learned something that's there.
That's there.
It's good that you took because he got the Nobel prize.
Now when he received the Nobel prize in this concept started being discussed,
what was the initial reaction to it?
Well,
it's interesting cause it,
it's allowed in Einstein's theory and it was in Einstein's original theory.
So it's car,
it's got a name,
it's called the cosmological constant.
And that's,
um,
it's,
it just allowed in the equations.
And Einstein actually introduced it initially to,
because I signed the equations,
strongly suggest that the universe is expanding or contracting and not just sat
there.
So even before we'd observed anything,
Einstein had a theory that suggested that the university just not static.
And,
and actually really strongly suggest that there's a beginning,
right?
So the,
the theory itself on its own suggests that you can see that if the universe is
stretching today,
that he must have been smaller in the past.
Right now,
everything must have been closer together.
Let's say that.
Um,
so the um,
as a magical George Lemaitre who was a,
who worked independently of Einstein,
but the same time in the early 1920s,
before we even knew there were other galaxies beyond the Milky Way,
and they notice that the,
the equations suggest the universe might be stretching.
Um,
and so he wrote to Einstein and said,
your theory suggests there was a day without a yesterday cause he thought if
everything is expanding now than it must've been close together in the past.
And so there might be a time when it was all together and he was a priest.
Wow.
So it was a Belgian priest.
So I think,
I mean I wrote about this now it's just kind of mindset for station a bit,
but I think that he was more predisposed to accept what the equations were
telling him because a beginning,
an origin for priest is really a nice thing because it tells you the creation
event.
And Einstein tried to dodge it and put this allowed term enthuse equation,
which is the almost the stretchy term to say,
well,
if it's old,
if it's all kind of contract in or something,
can I put something in to make it stretch a bit,
to balance it all out so it can be eternal and you can't,
you can't make it eternal that way,
but eat.
So he tried it,
they took it out and called his biggest blunder,
responded,
no eco putting it in his biggest blunder,
or at least some people think what he'd done was miss the prediction of the big
bang.
Really?
So by trying to fiddle around to have a static universe that stable,
he missed what the equations were screaming.
His own theory was screaming to him,
which is that no,
the universe expands or contracts and he missed it,
right?
So I think that's probably what he meant by biggest blunder.
But in any case,
it took it out.
And then later in the 1990s it turns out the notes there.
But it's really small.
It's tiny,
tiny effect.
But it still dominate in the universe now.
And it will,
and it will dominate even more in the future.
So we think that we're in the universe that will continue to expand,
essentially doubling in size on a fixed time scale in which is about 20 billion
years.
So within every 20 billion years into the future forever,
unless something happens,
the universe will continue to,
to expand and double in size.